a lot of people seem to be using this
tragedy to beat the drums of war and
feed the military industrial complex do
you worry about
this the people who
are rooting for escalation and how can
it be stopped one of the things that
does concern me is that there are very
few people alive today who actually
viscerally understand the horrors of War
at least in the US I mean obviously
there people in on the front lines in
Ukraine and Russia who understand just
how terrible war is um but how many
people in the west understand it um you
know my grandfather was in World War II
uh he was severely traumatized I mean he
was there I think in for almost six
years in the you in East North Africa in
Italy uh all his friends were killed uh
in front of him and uh he would have
died too um except they randomly gave
some I guess IQ test or something and uh
he scored very high um now he was not an
officer he was a I think a Corporal or a
sergeant or something like that um
because he didn't finish High School um
he had to drop out of high school
because his his his dad died and he had
to work to support his um siblings um so
because he didn't graduate high school
he was not eligible for the officer
Corp um so you know he kind of got put
into the cannon fighter category
basically um but then randomly that gave
him this test he was transferred to
British intelligence in London that's
where he met my grandmother um but uh he
he had PTSD next level like next level I
mean just didn't talk just didn't talk
and if you tried talking to him he'd
just tell you to shut up and he woron a
bunch of medals never never bragged
about it once not even they hinted
nothing I like found out about it
because I his military records are
online that's a how I know so he would
say like no no way in hell do you want
to do you want to do that again but how
many people um now he he obviously he
died you know 20 years ago well longer
actually 30 years ago
um how many people are alive that
remember World War II not
many